hello my name's Chris Krause mayor we'll
be covering the modeling and comparing
cloud solutions costs and strategy arc
two one three session for Google first
quick introduction my name's Chris gross
Meyer i'm senior director product for
cloud physics in Santa Clara California
I received the roadmap strategy and the
integration of some of the assessment
tools used by Google and the partners to
help the customers do assessments
costing and planning our agenda for
today we're gonna take a quick look at
analyzing your environment I'm gonna see
how to assess and discover your
workloads quantifying your data your TCO
and what's on premise and take a quick
dive into planning your cloud migration
and then ultimately deploy and optimize
following the basic cloud migration
strategy from Google so before we begin
most important thing I want to point out
find a cloud partner most customers will
are only going to succeed when they have
a strategic partner on board who has
done this multiple times take advantage
a partner learn from their experience
use their resources and train your staff
up with these solutions partners have
been able to do these services have
direct relationships with Google take
advantage of their knowledge and help
that migration go as smooth and as quick
the first time as possible also if your
partner take advantage of the funded
assessments from Google if you're a
partner or a user you can take advantage
of requesting a fully funded Google
assessment to analyze your current
infrastructure do the matching do the
TCO and analysis and find the best
output and solution for your cloud
migration strategy this can save weeks
or months for many organizations so as a
partner you can sign up the cloud
physics site and register and also for
new users you can also request an
assessment through the customer portal
or from close physics directly so as a
begin and you start working with your
partner communicate why you're
interested in exploring the cloud for
migration before you can really advance
down this journey what is the reason
that you're getting into the cloud begin
with how will be used production test
staging dev we want to know our workload
state floor stateless and you can take
advantage of some of the dynamics of the
cloud
are you going to take advantage of cloud
services or do you have lots of legacy
applications you're bringing over so are
you reap platforming rebuilding is their
compliance implication you're focused on
your trying to keep your workloads all
together on dedicated hardware in a
secure environment or are you okay with
going to a instance based scenario or do
somewhere close actually you really need
to stay within your own data center as
well as for compliancy you need to keep
the patch management and the resources
up-to-date is there a business impact
for this cost as well are we going to
gain a pop X or cap back savings can we
depreciate resources can we eliminate
some of the costs in the investments
that we have on-premise ultimately at
the end which tier applications are we
bringing over there do we need to run
our most mission critical application in
the cloud to take advantage of disaster
recovery and scalability or do we want
to take advantage of cloud for
elasticity for our developers our tests
in our staging environments and keeping
our workloads contained and controlled
by our own organization so as we begin
the very first step in an assessment and
the GCP model is analyze your
environment we want to do a quick look
of what we're going to do and sort of
define an outcome like we mentioned are
we moving to the cloud for a specific
reason are we trying to save money are
we trying to move a specific outcome are
we trying to reap lat form an
application or just do an application
renewal by defining the outcome your
stakeholders have a clear compass to
know whether you're moving the right
direction and which choices you should
focus on sole tenant instances Google
Cloud view more engine services and so
on those are all going to have a very
unique characteristic and the outcome
will really help guide that scenario as
we begin the financial needs are the
first place we want to begin on premise
we want to start quantifying the
resources on our side first we'll
quantify the cost of the cloud a little
bit later but we need to know are we
looking at all of our resources and what
is the cost on premise this is gonna
allow us to do comparisons later in the
lifecycle so on premise I want to build
a TCO model
I want to quantify what are my opposites
on premise and are we interested in
doing a pay-as-you-go or on-demand type
model where we're paying to keep
resources on there and then we're gonna
shut them on and off
not getting any significant discounts or
are we going to commit to a sustained
usage or committed use discount for some
of the workloads
there is also costs around migration are
we going to have to re platform an
application move it on to a new
operating system and spend many
man-hours of actually testing and
migrating workloads or can we just do a
quick B motion and bring that workload
of the cloud knowing that it's going to
work exactly as it did on premise
lastly changes in the infrastructure to
terms of operating systems if we own our
own licenses can we bring their own
licenses to the cloud should we leverage
standard instances in the cloud
available from the cloud provider or
should we go ahead and leverage a free
operating system and change the model by
which we're using os's today as we begin
a key part of this analysis is to have a
migration team we wanted to find who are
the stakeholders both at the line of
business and an IT and in the partner
each of you will have an impact on the
direction that we move the applications
and we define the business stakeholders
and we wanted to find the architecture
team so as we engage in application we
know why we're moving it are we moving
it for performance reasons are we moving
it to take advantage of certain platform
are we trying to get closer to our
customers these people are all going to
have a say and an input on how we
migrate and why we make migration
decisions so part of this TCO analysis
and the financial analysis to look at
what we have today we won't understand
what is the quantity of resources we
have in our data center what are our
servers what are the varying costs and
age of those resources that we've
invested in do we have a significant
investment in licenses for management
things like multi path things like
operating systems things like
virtualized storage and virtualized
Network or just general Enterprise
Management as a whole are we paying for
additional services on this platform
third-party applications that we're
using the cloud for today and are those
going to be able to carry over to the
cloud or those things that will end we
look at the end of our app on-premise
infrastructure also quantifying the
overhead of our infrastructure power and
cooling square footage maybe even the
cost of staff if some of them are
dedicated purely to operational you
on premise all these we want to quantify
in tune is TCO type analysis and find
out what is the cost of our resources on
premise once we've done that we can
actually take this even further some of
the tools and actually find out what is
the cost per workload was the cost per
VM what is the cost per hour per day per
year for an individual workload in our
data center and this is going to be very
useful as we start modeling these
resources into the cloud model what
metrics also matter is going to be
important for us we want to go through
and look at all of our workloads and
determine is there something unique
about the characteristics on-premise
that we're trying to fix we want more
performance of the disk level we want to
eliminate contention at the CPU we want
to eliminate memory swapping and
overcommitted hosts these metrics that
we monitor on-premise and collect data
for are something that we want to use as
the baseline so as we get to the cloud
later we can go back and see have we
actually improved her performance and
actually improved our experience for our
users by capturing these resources today
and seeing where the bottlenecks and the
problems are we can monitor those those
metrics when we get to the cloud and do
that comparison and actually quantify if
we've actually achieved a significant
improvement in our availability our
performance or just the day-to-day
operations so once you've done the TCO
analysis on premise the next part is
sort of start planning of cloud
migration we want to look at what are
the scenarios that we're going to look
at and then use those to build their
financial costs we can get into
comparison a little bit later so the
first thing to know and this is a good
tip is that everything or that
everything can or should move to the
cloud file and print servers domain
controllers potentially if you have
large hyper-converged infrastructure you
may have infrastructure for it such as
storage arrays and network components
that are virtualized on-premise that
don't need to move to the cloud so take
your time review the workloads that you
have on-premise tag them manage them and
quantify which ones you really want to
move to the cloud which ones aren't
necessary you may find that there's a
large portion of your investment powered
off VMs resources are dedicated to
on-premise restore
that don't need to go to the cloud and
can be a significant cost savings so
focus on what you have locally work on
those resources tag them and we'll use
those for filtering and reducing our
scope a little bit later
so in our workload analysis keep part of
what we have on premise is each workload
has a defined size every application
owner has come to you and said I want 16
or 32 processors I want 64 gigs of RAM I
want all the storage obviously they have
a business need for their requests but
the reality is they may not have ever
used those resources so no right sizing
the workload it's going to be very key
giving the users the opportunity to
reassess what is the ideal size of that
workload can have a significant cost
savings for us in the cloud there's no
reason to pay for 32 cpus when the
workload has never used more than 4 or 8
CPUs in the premise environment in
addition we want to map these workloads
to different instances as we start doing
the analysis the tools that we want to
leverage today we want to find every
work load and find out what is the ideal
workload in that new environment right
sizing it first and then mapping it into
those resources so we may find that
instead of 16 we can get by of 8 CPUs
and 64 gigs of ram would get by 24 by
mapping these instances after the right
sizing we can now quantify a cost for
each one of those based instance types
storage has an additional level of
optimization all to its own many
workloads on-premise have performance
characteristics that are limited by the
array in the cloud we can choose SSD or
hard drive or even optimal so based on
the I ops in the throughput of that
specific application we may recommend
that it go to an SSD but the volume is
large enough or the performance is low
enough maybe we can put it onto a hard
disk drive using the tools and knowing
what the metrics are for each workload
allows us to dynamically adjust these
on-the-fly and the end result will have
a cost that's optimized for each
workload lastly there's some choices
that we need to make around how we want
to put these on the cloud traditionally
we'd always put resources out there as
instances in the Google cloud where
every operating system got it
instance on a shared resource in the
infrastructure but with the invent of
sole tenant nodes we can move our own
workloads onto a dedicated host which is
only occupied by our own organization
and not shared with anybody else true
advantage of sole tenant nodes also is
over subscription so what if I have a
lot of idle or lightly used workloads
throughout the month I can over
subscribe this host potentially up to
four to one and gain the benefit of over
subscription that I couldn't do with
with individual instances lastly the
newly released Google Cloud VMware
engine allowing us to run workloads in
VMware on Google cloud as a dedicated
node big cost savings to move workloads
just with a V motion from on-premise to
the cloud without having to go through
any replac forming or any migration
lastly what are your deciding factors is
it time do I need to be on the cloud as
quick as possible is it I need to
refresh or are my replac from an
application and modernized in my
applications all these are going to be
important factors for our workload
analysis as we start modeling we want to
start looking at the characteristics are
going to have an impact for each
instance choosing a geography will have
an impact on cost immediately so knowing
that I have a specific geography in mind
I can move it to wherever I want for the
maximum cost savings or have it as close
to an end user community that uses an
application I can explore that sole
tenant node option taking advantage of
dedicated hosts and with dedicated hosts
the ability to bring my own Microsoft
licenses to the cloud and take advantage
my own Software Assurance if you're a
VMware customer today and you have a g
vce Google Cloud virtual or VMware
engine option available to you move
those work clothes directly into VMware
in the cloud and potentially have a
significant savings in time and cost of
infrastructure but importantly we want
to understand what our commitments are
as we commit to those resources in time
on demand or one-year or three-year
commits we will achieve different levels
of discount for each one of these
solutions
lastly understand the skills and
capabilities
of your team as well so as I run through
this simulation and I'm mapping my
workloads to the cloud if I'm planning
to move them into instances or I'm
planning to move them to services or is
my team or my partner capable of doing
that or will I gain the advantage of
just vmotion these workflows into the
cloud and then learning that skill as we
go through them one at a time
but gain the advantage of getting on the
cloud as quickly as possible so a big
choice jump all in or go hybrid if I
jump all in am I gonna do one fail swoop
and bring it all to the cloud or can I
run in a hybrid mode where I bring
specific applications to the cloud one
at a time keeping some of my resources
on-premise in my own data center and run
those in the cloud as I bring them over
I need to understand what needs to stay
what needs to go understand the
relationship between these resources is
also important if I have lots of traffic
between two VMs I want to ensure that I
bring all the relevant resources with me
to the cloud at the same time so this is
where we get into discussion of what
options and impact each has if we adopt
Google cloud services we can see a
significant savings by taking out the
operating system in the instance classes
and focusing solely on the service so
adopting Google cloud services for cloud
sequel ASAP on google kubernetes any of
the advanced machine learning engines
and resources can be a significant cost
savings over running instances for you
as an organization giving you true
dynamic capabilities but I may have to
do some lift and shift I may have
applications that are legacy
applications Windows 2003 and those
resources that I want to bring to the
cloud so do I bring those applications
on to new OS instances on the cloud or
do I just migrate that workload things
like Bella strata streamlined that
automation for us or quickly migrate
with the Google cloud VMware engine if I
have a legacy infrastructure today and
time is of the essence quickly be
motioning those workloads over to the
cloud may offer a quick advantage but
ultimately may mean some of these
applications remain around much longer
than you intend either bring it to the
cloud doesn't necessarily mean that's
going to end up getting read platform
we look at the instance options we want
to look at all the factors that impact
our instance choices we talked about
right sizing and do we optimize those
resources knowing that an application is
multi-threaded and takes advantage of
multiple CPUs right sizing it down may
actually have an impact on its
performance so we definitely want to
engage for the lines of business and the
application owners around this
optimizing storage for disk type if we
are bandwidth constrained at the disk
level where IO and throughput constraint
taking advantage of SSDs in the cloud
may give us a significant performance
increase or maybe changing the storage
model altogether dev test QA all the
different staging maybe they don't need
to be on full instances moving them to
on demand or pre-emptive instances could
offer significant savings for us and
have a big impact on the long term
strategy lastly choosing the right
instance class is something we want to
start with right away focusing on what
is it that we need do we need an Intel
processor for the Intel Architecture and
the Intel commands am I going to go with
the latest and fastest Intel processor
am I gonna go with something where I
really don't know the underlying
infrastructure for costumes that can eat
- instance or maybe I have a commitment
to an AMD solution that's in the
infrastructure and I know that I have an
AMD processor need choosing each of
these will have a financial impact cost
will reveal that through the tools and
the calculations sole tenant nodes
versus Google Cloud VMware engine a
strategic choice here is that I can over
commit sole tenant nodes and take
advantage of bringing my own licenses
over instances I can do the same with
the VMware engine but with the VMware
engine I can leverage my VMware
architecture as it is today take
advantage of the VMware tools but the
Google cloud is going to allow me to do
some functionalities very specifically
to the cloud without paying for the
addition of an older of the hypervisor
overhead I'm not going to need VMware in
the cloud maybe I don't need to bring it
to the Google cloud the amore engine one
of the key things of sole tenant nodes
and the GCV dcve is that I can bring my
own licenses for the Microsoft solution
where I can always bring my licenses for
Linux solutions to instances of
limitations of Microsoft like
allows me to bring those licenses to
those dedicated OHS models so a big
discussion options around optimization
and the impact of each so if we're
willing to commit to resources we want
to take advantage of the discounts we
can achieve if we commit to a on demand
instance and the workloads are going to
be out a lot we want to leave them on as
much as possible to gain that sustained
usage discounts on demand and
pre-emptive we'll gain that advantage
for sustained use but if I'm willing to
commit to a year or three year I can get
even greater savings with that committed
use discount is it going to apply to all
of our instances and convert them into
regular instances on the instance model
for the sole tenant node and the GCV II
it's committing to the infrastructure
over one year or three year to maximize
that savings so as I go through these
calculations I want to know all these
factors did I match the right resource I
choose the right storage that I choose
the right commitment that I choose the
right geography all those are gonna play
into our scenario here
so once we've gone through and played
with some of the assessment tools you're
going to have the capability of doing
comparisons we did that early TCO we
modeled what their cost was on-premise
we're actually able to find that cost
per VM we're actually able to do that
same modeling then against the cloud
instance what was the cost of that
single VM in the cloud on a sole tenant
node or as an instance no your current
support services versus future support
services if you have resources and
people on site and you're paying for
those on-premise how are those going to
be impacted if you can cut those costs
or are you going to be picking up
additional services on the cloud side
things like security logging load
balancing different concepts of the
infrastructure certificate management
and support all are gonna plane just to
your cost model comparisons lastly we
want to plan for the disaster recovery
scenario fortunately for us Google takes
care of the hardware infrastructure for
us should a host fail it bring back the
resources for us so I don't need to
build an N plus 1 n plus 2 architecture
but I do want to plan for corruption and
loss of data so planning for a storage
and archiving
back up scenario it's going to be key as
we get to the cloud as well
once we've dialed this we'll collect all
the data through the assessment models
this is where a tool like the cloud
physics analysis is going to be critical
we're going to bring all of our content
in we're gonna start prioritizing our
aggregation of components now
TTIP here do I move my most critical
application first move the low-hanging
fruit
there should be an obvious one we want
the team to learn by moving some of the
resources first let them test and and
learn how the tools work how they
respond learn for compatibility learn
for build restrictions and different
builds and versions that are out there
that may not be compatible with each
other let them unlearn on the platform
by bringing that low-hanging fruit the
test environment the dev environment
before you commit to the larger
enterprise hopefully a strategic partner
if they're involved with you can give
you a lot of heads up to a lot of these
but ultimately you know your
applications
you know the limits and the requirements
and testing is going to be really
critical for your team to focus on in
the early stages so our last big portion
of the planning is going to be deploying
optimize in the Google model so where we
can we want to use the services if we
have mail and exchange on-premise maybe
we take advantage of google mail we have
exchange servers on-premise if we can
use cloud sequel we can take advantage
of the services that make the most sense
if we can achieve a cost savings in many
cases if it's an instance today
on-premise and you can bring it to the
cloud we can find a similar service that
has reduced cost we want to monitor what
you are consuming what are you using
on-premise we're using the cloud and
what was used for certain portions of it
because your utilization during
migration or during peak usage may be
significantly different throughout the
year so if you're doing an assessment in
the off season understand what you're
consuming optimize resources that make
sense for your small dev tests and QA
instances or developer desktops making
them smaller because they're idle is
fine but for an application that takes
advantage of that multi-threaded
environment has lots of cores
maybe optimization isn't critical as as
availability
formitz so understand what the business
need is before your right size are
optimize those resources a big portion
this is cloud service integration if I
can integrate to a cloud service or do I
want to be cloud agnostic and bring my
own OS instances my own applications the
tighter I get coupled into the cloud the
more savings and maybe it will achieve
but the harder is to move later
ultimately kubernetes and containers if
I'm going stateless or I have a lot of
resources that are very dynamic being
traded on the fly take advantage of the
new technologies for kubernetes allow
your environment to use things like
anthos and leverage the container model
it's really save resources as we move so
an optimisation decision points here so
does your staff have the skill set now
required for cloud management if they
were strong in the VMware tools maybe
the VMware tools on the cloud makes more
sense if they're really just strong on
their core applications and the
infrastructure was not their strong
point cloud migration may be a very
simple choice for you to make the cost
of migration lifting and shifting
resources to the cloud or running tools
to do a VM migration can be very costly
versus just doing something as simple as
a V motion right sizing and REE
platforming is key to the solution or
application modernization is key to the
solution you're going to incur more cost
upfront but a V motion will get me on
the cloud and get me over there quicker
that can focus on the resources in the
cloud and not pay for that inter region
bandwidth type scenarios does your cost
benefit from Sultanat nodes or shared
infrastructure the more I can
oversubscribe the more I can commit my
resources the better I can over
subscribe my host because a lot of my
workloads are relatively idle that's a
big cost advantage but if my workloads
are one to one for CPUs and I want to
guarantee a commitment again sole tenant
nodes and may offer an advantage that I
can add my own resource my own host not
shared with anybody else but the cost of
shared infrastructure may be a negative
in that case again operating systems
we've touched on this many times there
is a significant advantage to bringing
your own operating systems if
you've already invested in an Software
Assurance and you have a multi-year
agreement with a software manufacturer
or a license manager for the operating
systems bring your own like since the
cloud guarantees your investment is not
lost it allows you to bring that
resource over and reuse it if you own
Linux you can do BYO l across all
instances and all solutions but byl for
Windows environment only applies to the
sole tenant nodes and the Google Cloud
VMware engine last big choice will free
do you may find that a lot of the free
operating systems may be sufficient for
what you're looking for if I don't need
an enterprise class Red Hat instance and
get by with a free Linux version it may
be sufficient for some of your
non-critical applications so some final
thoughts plan tests migrate learn repeat
this is going to be key to the success
leverage that partner go through these
steps multiple times
start with the low-hanging fruit bring
those resources over the cloud learn
what works and doesn't and then repeat
and correct it's going to be an
important factor for bringing these
resources over so with that I'm gonna
say thank you a quick final note though
there are resources available from the
Google team there is a great guide for
planning your google cloud migration
we'll get into all of the assessment
models the tools and the financial
planning portions of it as well as cloud
physics does provide a full assessment
model fully funded by Google and it's
available to all partners to offer to
their customers and for all customers to
take advantage of directly from Google
visit the site learn how to sign up for
the assessment and will guide you
through both the on-premise TCO and as
what as well as all the cloud modeling
for your storage your compute and all
the new resources and you're looking at
in the cloud with that I want to say
thank you very much joy the rest of the
conference and have a good day